nein da gibt schlimmere titel bei uns
wobei die immer aus dem interview
einsatz nehmen also wird unterstellen
nur wir nehmen natürlich den krassesten
so logisch wir versuchen aber trotzdem
dass die erwartung nicht durch werden
werde dann eben nicht irgendein fehl
satz wo wir jemand ja aber das muss man
machen aber die leute guckt mal wenn sie
nicht gucken sie auch doof
dann könnte ich jetzt zum beispiel seien
die lampe erinnert mich ganz schön doll
an du [__]
okay wir waren
ja hier ist kitty kat ich sitze mit
meiner pink mafia bei klicks und darf
das erste schau dort machen das ist hier
jemals gab die karten check klicks